new york governor andrew cuomo is under  fire this afternoon an investigation is  looking into multiple  accusations of him sexually harassing  women  new york attorney general leticia james  summarized the findings today  she said that cuomo is also accused of  working to retaliate  against one of his accusers the  investigation found that  governor andrew cuomo sexually harassed  current  and former new york state employees by  engaging in unwelcome  and non-consensual touching and making  numerous offensive comments  of a suggestive and sexual nature  that created a hostile work environment  for women today's findings have renewed  calls for cuomo's resignation or  impeachment  the governor responded to the findings  today saying that quote the facts are  much different than what  has been portrayed cuomo appeared to  reject calls to resign